GUSTAVO MOREIRA: Do you
want to get your iOS
apps on the big screen?
Well, we have made it
easier than ever before.
Hi.
I'm Gustavo Moreira from the
Google Developer Relations
team.
And I'm going to talk to you
about the Google Cast SDK
version 3 for iOS.
In June in 2016, we
launched a new version 3 API
for the Google Cast SDK.
That new Cast SDK
simplifies several parts
of the previous Google Cast SDK
and addresses the major pain
points identified by content
partners and developers.
The new Cast SDK greatly
reduces the amount
of code needed by
providing UI widgets that
fully comply with the
Cast UX design checklist.
First, here's some terminology
about how Casting works.
The Google Cast
sender application
refers to an app running on
a mobile device or laptop.
And the receiver application
refers to an HTML application
running on a Chromecast or
any other Google Cast receiver
devices.
Let's take a quick look
at the typical lifecycle
off a Cast sender app.
When the Cast sender
app is launched,
Cast receiver devices
need to be discovered
on the local network.
Once the user selects a
device, the sender app
will connect to that device
and launch the receiver app.
The sender app then
creates a message channel
to the receiver app to
send and receive messages.
The user can also disconnect
from that device at any time.
The new SDK implements
these new features.
UI widgets that comply with the
Google Cast design checklist,
notification and
lock screen controls,
automatic device
discovery, so you
don't have to manage
that in your code,
centralized cast session
state management,
and a reconnection service
that automatically handles
network issues to
keep your sender app
connected to the receiver.
Even when a user
leaves their room
and goes out of the
range of the network,
the session will be
automatically reconnected
when the user returns.
To get your hands
on the new SDK,
you just need to install the
Google Cast SDK version 3
or higher from cocoapods.
Make sure to use iOS 8.0
as the deployment platform.
Let's take a look at how
to add Cast to your app.
The Cast framework has a global
singleton object, the GCK Cast
context, which coordinates
all the cast interactions.
You must create a Cast
options object to initialize
to Cast context singleton.
The most important option is
the receiver application ID,
which you get from the Google
Cast Developer Console.
You can then get the
Cast context instance
by using the static
shared instance method.
You can also set
a default logger
to the logger shared instance.
For your app's UI, the first
step in supporting Cast
is to add the Cast button.
The SDK provides a
Cast button widget
that automatically manages
its visibility and state,
and provides all the
necessary dialogs for user
to select and
disconnect devices.
The Cast button
UI is a UI button
that can be added to
the Navigation bar
as a ride bar button item.
Just initialize the Cast
button with the proper size,
and add it to the
Navigation bar.
When a user selects a Cast
device using the Cast button
menu, a new Cast session
is started automatically
by the framework.
All these
interactions, including
backing out of this menu,
are handled by the widget.
The list of devices
is filtered based
on the app ID configuration
in the Google Cast Developer
Console.
For the Cast framework,
a Cast session
encapsulates the
connection to a device,
managing the
receiver application,
and initializing a media control
channel for the media apps.
Cast sessions are managed by
the session manager, which
can be accessed via the
session manager property
on the Cast context object.
The GCK session manager
listener callbacks
can be used to monitor session
events such as creation,
suspension, resumption,
and termination.
To play media on the
receiver, the sender app
has to the media metadata
of the media stream.
Here you can see how it just
add the media type, title,
and images using the
media metadata class.
And here you can see how it just
add the media URL, string type,
and other metadata using
the media information class.
The remote media
client class is then
used to load a media
stream on the receiver.
The sender app then invokes
commands such as play and pause
using the remote media client.
The sender app can use the
session manager listener
callbacks to track
the session estate,
and decide when to enable and
disable the local media player.
As required by the
Cast UX guidelines,
the SDK provides a widget
called the mini controller that
appears when the user navigates
away from the current content
page to another part of the app.
The mini controller
provides instant access
to playback controls
and a visible reminder
for the current Cast session.
The Cast SDK provides
a custom field
UI mini controls view
controller, which
can be created from
the Cast context object
and added to any container
view in your app.
The Google Cast
design checklist also
requires a sender app to
provide an expanded controller
for the media being cast.
The expanded controller
is a full screen version
of the MIDI controller.
The Cast SDK provides a widget
for the expanded controller
that can be presented directly
from the Cast context object.
To add an expanded
controller, just enable it
in the Act Delegate Affair app.
In the Did Finish Launching
with Options method,
just enable the default
expanded media controls off
the SDK in the Cast
context object.
The Cast SDK provides
a custom view
called Call Cast Instructions
View Controller that
can be used to highlight a
Cast button when it's first
shown to users.
This code shows how you can use
the Cast Context Present Cast
Instructions View
Controller Once method
to show the overlay in your
app only the first time
the user accesses it.
That's everything you need
to Cast enable your app.
You can get more details
about the Google Cast SDK
at developers.Google.com/cast.
We have also open source
sample Cast apps that you
can use as a reference.
And if you have any
developer questions,
pose those on the
Stack Overflow.
Join our Google Cast developers
community on G+ to keep up
to date with SDK updates and
to chat with other developers
and share ideas.
Thanks for watching,
and see you next time.
[MUSIC PLAYING]